before we move on a quick reminder do
check out our South Ridge on Sunday
podcast it features the best bits from
the show plus some extra analysis for me
and my producing that just go to the sky
news app Spotify or Apple podcasts to
find that now we know the older people
are particularly vulnerable to
coronavirus and many over 70s are having
to isolate at home we've all heard of a
difficult situation being faced by care
homes that we were discussing with a
grant chaps earlier as well and to talk
about that a little bit more we're
joined by the former Pensions Minister
Baroness Rose Altman thank you so much
for being on the program whatever
happens next Thursday it feels as if
many many older people many older 70s
are going to be having to stick to this
strict social distancing rules or even a
south isolate for some months to come do
you think that's right well I certainly
hope that as we move out of the current
emergency phase of lockdown there won't
be some kind of blanket policy to forbid
people of any particular age from
leaving their own homes or from being
part of the community I think using an
age based criteria would be
fundamentally wrong and actually would
potentially cost the lives of many
people and risks social unrest that's
interesting and what do you mean by
social unrest well there are so many
over 70s who can't bear the thought of
having to stay in lockdown a moment
longer and have accepted it obviously
because everyone else has got to do it
but if they're fit and healthy and they
need to get out for their own sanity and
for their own physical health then the
idea that the government will tell them
you are under house arrest while
everybody else is free and you're forced
into solitary confinement which of
course is often the case many older
people are on their own and rely on this
interaction with other people for their
own basic needs of life then I think
that they wouldn't accept it certainly
lots of them have told me the
they would rebel and they would risk
going to prison rather than being forced
to isolate at home it's interesting
because as we learn more about this
disease and here is most at risk whether
it's you if you're overweight if you're
male if you're from a DME background I
just wonder do you think that it's right
that we ask older people as a blanket
ban if it's a healthy woman for example
age 70 to do something that perhaps we
wouldn't ask all men or all those from
ethnic minority backgrounds to do is
that age discrimination course it's age
discrimination there's no other way to
look at it you know a healthy seventy
year old is probably less risk to
society than an unhealthy 40 year old in
terms of vulnerability to this illness
of course the death rates or the number
of people all the people dying are
higher than the number of younger people
the number of older people dying of
anything is always higher than the
number of young people dying that's why
life insurance for a 20 or 30 year old
cost very little but by the time you
reach age 60 or 70 it costs a fortune
that's because the probability of dying
as you get older increases but that's
not necessarily an indication that Kovac
itself is going to strike down a healthy
70 year old any more than it's going to
strike down a healthy 40 year old
unless the 70 year old has other
conditions and the fact is we live in a
free country don't wring most older
people would be sensible enough just to
know when they need to stay at home and
also to know when they need to go out if
the government wants to advise people
and say look if you're more at risk
don't consider going out unless it's
vital that's different from formally
mandating that people of a certain age
must all be locked up as if they're a
homogeneous group which they're not and
as if their lives don't count in the
same way as others and and that is
something that I think we absolutely as
a society need to get to grips with this
idea that just because someone is old
their frail they're vulnerable and
they're not fit or or they're not worthy
of the same treatment as other age
groups is utterly wrong and I hope that
we can get away from that as soon as
possible I mean you say there that older
people have been treated as their lives
don't count I guess the government would
argue that the opposite is happening
that there is a strong age profile when
it comes to cope at 19 you can see it
we've all seen that the tables and what
they're trying to do is to protect those
people in the older age category well
I'm telling you that protecting them
means allowing them to get out and go
about their lives as soon as possible
for many and as you said at the
beginning nobody what dream of saying
that all non-whites must stay under
house arrest but everyone else can go
free okay reality is that more pame
people sadly falling victim to this than
others but somehow it's not okay to
discriminate on grounds of gender or
obesity or color of skin but everybody
is saying that let's think about somehow
discriminating on the basis of ages if
the older people are okay to
discriminate against and it's not
correct
okay now I'm keen to talk to you a bit
as well about care homes and the
situation in care homes and you know one
of the real tragedies I suppose of
absolutely that we've seen more than
4,000 deaths in care homes involving
coronavirus between the 10th and 24th of
April alone when Sky News is visited
care homes where they believe more than
half of residents have coronavirus have
they been abandoned they certainly feel
abandoned and what we are seeing is an
extension of potentially this ageist
attitude but it's also allied to our
system of social care which is treated
as second-class relative to health care
so the NHS is totemic and
if something is considered to be
healthcare it's somehow sacrosanct and
everybody must get it for free at the
point of need
if something's considered social care
somehow it's okay to say you have to pay
for all of it yourself and we're not
going to focus on it we're leaving it to
cash-strapped councils now that in my
view is a false and artificial
distinction both are about health and
both are about care so we need to
integrate the system and I know the
government wants to do this I know the
government has been looking for ways to
do this but what this crisis has done is
highlight the way in which the NHS has
pushed out the focus on social care even
though those people who are relying on
social care whether it's in a care home
or indeed relying on care in their own
home have not received the focus they
have not received the attention and
indeed you have stories of hospitals
discharging people back into care homes
either knowing they have coded or not
having tested for Ovid which has
resulted in those people living close by
others who are also potentially
vulnerable because that's where our
frailest elderly people are living also
catching the disease we haven't had the
same that supply of PPE in testing for
care homes we we have focused on
hospitals we focused on freeing up
capacity in the NHS we now have tens of
thousands of spare beds across our
hospitals across the country and yet the
older people in care homes who could and
should be really looked after in a
hospital setting have been thrown back
into the care system at the mercy of
councils and local authorities and a
different structure that he's not
looking after them in the same way as
the NHS I think you're certainly one of
things I found most extraordinary add
that people who've been taken from
Hospice
to care home either with caboodle
without having been tested that didn't
change till mid-april
Rosalind thank you very much today thank
you